37 years ago john murray made a promise
to yvonne fletcher as she lay dying
he would find who was responsible for
shooting her as they policed an
anti-gaddafi protest at the libyan
embassy in april 1984
and he never gave up
we have proven we were right all along
sally abraham abrupt
was responsible for yvonne's murder
the courtroom erupted in applause as the
high court judge announced that colonel
gaddafi's close aid may not have pulled
the trigger but was jointly liable for
what had happened
he knew there were guns he did nothing
to stop their use and he made sure
pro-qadhafi protesters were out of the
line of fire number one number two
that's where the shots came from
mcbrooke was arrested in connection with
yvonne fletcher's death in 2015 but the
case was later dropped as some evidence
could not be revealed for reasons of
national security
i hope that the cps now will review
their original decision not to charge mr
criminal matters if they don't then i
may well take a a private criminal
prosecution mcbrooke isn't allowed in
the country and chose not to be
represented in the case
during the trial the court heard how mr
murray had suffered guilt about what had
happened to his close friend and
colleague here in saint james's square
all those years ago
but himself welling up the judge mr
justice martin spencer said rather than
feel guilty mr murray should feel proud
of how he conducted himself
the nation mourned the young police
officer's death she was only 25
a memorial service in the square where
she died was attended by the prime
minister at the time margaret thatcher
[Music]
for john bringing the case to court was
never about the money he was only
fighting for one pound in damages
this was about a vow made to a dying
friend
a promise which he has finally fulfilled
emma birchley sky news central london